well we're going to have some winds
picking up some speed as we get through
our thursday right into friday and over
the weekend in fact gustier winds
expected saturday and sunday ragweed oak
and grasses still blooming out there and
that pollen is just going to swirl
around once we get the winds going
moderate air quality for ozone because
of the heat that we'll have for the next
couple of days this will probably be the
hottest day or the rest of the forecast
and boy we've got a big drop in
temperatures by memorial day lots of
70's around henderson back up 80 degrees
the strip at 79 74 for the lakes
summerlin red rock right now 79 in seven
hills outside the valley pahrump is
right at 70 degrees with mid 60's for
indian springs 77 for boulder city 79 in
laughlin with 70's
kingman you popped up to the low 70's
you were in the 60's just the last hour
55 for caliani and 51 or 51 for cali any
55 for cedar city a lot of rain and
thunderstorms in the eastern half of the
u.s let's go right down to the gulf
coast where there are tornado watch
boxes now that stretch all the way from
mississippi through southern alabama and
into the panhandle of florida they are
looking for tornadoes now for the next
several hours as some of these
thunderstorms have become very intense
bringing very heavy rain and high winds
and they're looking at twisting
formation there with these storms that
could turn into actual tornadoes in the
northwest we've got a new system this is
the beginning of it it will be stronger
and deeper and by the weekend as it
heads towards our area it will pick up
stronger winds and bring the cool air
with it 102 for today that's this will
be the hottest day southwest breezes to
about 25 miles an hour so breezy today
and friday ahead of that system moving
in but then as we start to feel the
presence of that system more even in the
southern great basin starts to take the
edge off the heat we'll see a few clouds
around and gustier winds 30 35 miles an
hour for the weekend look how the
temperatures drop to the 80s even low
80s for memorial day monday and then we
slowly get right back to those hotter
90s next week